[Música]
[Aplausos]
salve forçados ventos e parry 'olha eu
peço licença para entrar
salve mãe rainha odoiá eu peço licença
para entrar à força das águas de chupar
a purificar
eu peço licença para entrar
salve salve guerreiras amazonas eu peço
licença para entrar à força indígena
milenar
eu peço licença para entrar
quem veio antes de mim e quem ainda virá
eu peço licença para entrar dois moça
a gente pode conversar eu não quero
tomar muito do seu tempo eu só queria
para algumas coisinhas
eu preciso de uma pausa no meio da sua
rotina
eu sei da sua correria é a vida a
família casa cria comida e ainda nem deu
meio dia
você sabia que daqui eu escuto seus
pensamentos em guerra
eu também batalha comigo mesmo todos os
dias e até hoje não sei dizer muito bem
como fica esse placar
eu quero te fazer uma pergunta quantas
vezes você realmente se escuta e quantas
dessas obedece o seu pensar quando a
noite cai ea mente trabalha em silêncio
meu corpo por vezes me diz vai mais
reflito sobre tudo o que pensa nem
sempre o impulso é seguro nem sempre
traz acalento e por vezes peço pai
livrai me do que eu não sustenta
eu já pensei dispensei sem escutar eu já
pensei repensei após refletir
eu já ignorei sinais que vieram pra me
livrar
eu demorei pra aprender a me ouvir
você sabia
existe uma força dentro de todos nós uma
herança que nos acompanha desde as
nossas ancestrais
só é preciso estar atenta aos sinais
eu sei que existe um abismo entre a sua
razão e emoção e nos ensinaram muito bem
como trabalhar isso
afinal há milênios querem domesticar os
nossos instintos e é por isso que eu
insisto em te perguntar quantas vezes
você realmente se escuta e quantas
dessas obedece o seu pensar as
responsabilidades de uma mulher moderna
impedem que ela tenha tempo de se
questionar e enquanto cuidamos de tudo
ao nosso redor
esquecemos simplesmente de nos cuidar
quando compreendi o que dentro de mim
pulsava entende que eu sou a guia da
minha própria jornada
daí fui perceber o quanto me flagelava
buscando a minha auto destruição pelo
simples fato de não seguir a minha
intuição intuição substantivo feminino
ato de perceber discernir até mesmo
pressentir coisas independentemente de
raciocínio é resgatar sensações que
foram extintas entender que tudo é uma
questão de sintonia ser sensível e meio
ao caos andar na contra mão e não se
culpe por nem sempre consegui tudo bem
ninguém disse que seria fácil existir
apenas não crie barreiras em torno de si
mesma
busque sua força interna para reagir
eu escrevo pra expurgar os medos para
afastar a solidão em meio a tantos
enredos despertar o que me habita
desvendar meus próprios segredos
eu pedia desculpa toda vez depois de
falar como se fosse um erro
um defeito de nascença queremos colocar
ambiente está hostis nos tornam
prisioneiras de nossas próprias ideias
mas revoluções revoluções sempre foram
feitas a partir de distintos e d
mas seja o seu próprio néctar explora-se
multiverso mulher
regente o que tinha feta respeite o seu
tempo percebesse florescer e não se
preocupe quando precisar desaguar é
normal transbordar
entenda nós mulheres temos pacto com o
mar e as lágrimas
as lágrimas são remo diálise da alma
escuta essa voz interna que tenta se
comunicar não nega suas intuições confia
nelas de bruxas e sábias
todos temos um pouco o quanto disso você
consegue resgatar a minha intenção aqui
é fazer você refletir olhar para dentro
de si o seu momento presente porque o
seu corpo sente e como ele tenta se
comunicar para que a partir de agora
nesse momento você realmente se escute e
obedeça o seu pensar
obrigada
[Aplausos]